when it comes to choosing a powerful mac
to buy in 2019 you've got some really
great options but you're gonna have to
choose between being limited to a
desktop setup or a portable Mac that you
can take on the go so we decided to
compare the performance and usability of
the iMac versus the MacBook Pro to help
you guys decide which one you should buy
for the iMac we've got the
top-of-the-line 2019 model with the 8
core eye 9 processor and Vega 48
graphics which comes in at around three
thousand four hundred and fifty dollars
if you add in 32 gigabytes of RAM
yourself which we definitely recommend
you do now for the MacBook Pro we've got
the 2018 model with Vega 20 graphics 32
gigabytes of RAM in the mid-range 2.6
gigahertz six Core i7 processor for a
$3,550 just a hundred dollars more than
the iMac now you might be asking why not
shoot the i-9 processor well we've done
extensive testing with it and we found
that you get basically the same
performance as the i7 because the i9
suffers from so much thermal throttling
you can see all the juicy details in
this video above now I know these
machines are very pricey so a bit later
in the video we're also going to mention
the differences between the base models
of these machines so for the high-end
models let's get into performance and
Geekbench for single core test the iMac
scores around 13% faster and in
multi-core it's around 21 percent faster
now the graphics test is where the imax
new vega 48 graphic shines with almost
double the score of the MacBooks vega 20
which is the primary benefit of going
the desktop route now on to Cinebench
r15 cpu test which really taxes the
processors the iMac is now a massive 53
percent faster which really shows the
difference in cores and cooling
performance to test both graphics and
processing power together we ran unige
in heaven which is a realistic gaming
benchmark and saw that the iMac was
getting almost two times more FPS than
the MacBook Pro we previously tested a
few high-end games on the new 2018 iMac
and we got really good frame rates at
high settings whereas with the MacBook
you'll have trouble unless you hook up
in a GPU now let's get into some video
editing tests which are greatly affected
by graphics performance in our
stabilization tests the iMac finished
couple of seconds faster which can
really add up if you do a lot of
stabilization then exporting a
five-minute 4k h.264 clip there's
actually not much of a difference at all
now exporting an 8-bit h.265 clip the
iMac actually falls behind and takes
over twice as long to export that's
because the new iMac doesn't include
Apple's t2 chip which supports
outstanding hardware HT VC encoding now
exporting a 10-bit h.265 clip the imac
now blows the macbook out of the water
because 10-bit video and final cut
doesn't currently support hardware a TVC
encoding that comes with the t2 chip now
exporting 4.5 K red raw which is very
processor intensive the iMac is quite a
bit faster because the processor and
graphics performance boost over the
MacBook and we see the same thing
exporting 4k 60p Canon C 200 raw the
iMac is now almost twice as fast as the
MacBook and that's not the only
difference what really matters is being
able to edit the 60 frames per second
footage smoothly and that's just what
the iMac does running at a consistent 60
frames per second compared to only 30 on
the MacBook and that's what Vega 20
graphics with the previous high-end 560
X graphics we only got around 17 FPS on
this tests
so overall the iMac outperforms the
MacBook Pro except in the case of 8-bit
HEV see video editing due to the lack of
the t2 chip but for basically everything
else the iMac will perform much better
now let's say you need a Mac for basic
computer tasks or even high-end photo
editing the MacBook should really be
fine and perform close to as well as the
iMac since those tasks don't really use
the graphics now let's talk about some
of the highlights of both machines the
iMac is packing a beautiful 5k display
that you really have to try out to
appreciate its incredibly color accurate
bright and there's no comparison if
you're into multitasking you also get an
amazing variety of i/o compared to being
limited to a bunch of USB sea ports on
the MacBook you can an excellent mouse
and keyboard that seems to last forever
on a single charge and the 5k iMac
features a ram door on the back so you
can save literally hundreds of dollars
by upgrading it yourself but the obvious
downside is that it's not portable and
that's where the MacBook Pro really
shines the freedom of being able to take
your Mac out
bedroom or the office and taking onto
the couch to the coffee shop to your
friends place on an airplane or even
another country really makes a huge
difference and that's where you're
paying a premium for it
the design is incredible and thin the
display is great even though is nowhere
near as nice as a 5k iMac and the
speakers have really been upgraded this
year they're loud enough to comfortably
watch movies and shows with noise in the
background the only downside is the
butterfly keyboard that not many people
are fond of but I personally don't mind
it at all when I had the choice of
choosing between the iMac and a MacBook
I went with the MacBook because I'm able
to spend time around my wife on the
couch or anywhere else while doing work
on my Mac and sometimes that's worth it
over the extra performance now you can
also have the best of both worlds by
using an e GPU with the MacBook Pro if
you want to learn more about that check
out this video so what if you're on a
budget and don't want to spend that much
on your Mac let's quickly examine the
base 5k iMac and 15-inch MacBook Pro
2018 is the first year that you get a 6
core processor the t2 chip ddr4 ram and
four gigabytes of graphics memory all at
the base $2,400 price and it's currently
on sale on Amazon for only $2,100 with
prime shipping we'll leave a link down
below
now the 5k iMac starts at a base price
of only eighteen hundred dollars and you
get a similar six core processor in
faster graphics but I would highly
recommend paying the extra hundred
dollars for the SSD and updating the ram
yourself to a total of 40 gigabytes by
using the link below for only a hundred
and sixty-five dollars instead of
getting a total of 32 gigabytes from
Apple for $600 that's four hundred and
thirty-five dollars cheaper for even
more RAM that brings the total price of
the 5k IMAX to 2,000 $65 a bit less than
the MacBook Pro on sale
comparing Geekbench for multi-core
results the MacBook Pro is actually
slightly faster and comparing graphics
performance the iMac is over twice as
fast so you will see a big difference in
graphically intensive tasks and this
time the base iMac gets quick sync
technology but it still lacks the t2
chips HEV C encoding that comes with the
MacBook Pro either way unless you're
doing something graphically intensive
like video editing you really won't
notice much of a difference in
performance so the MacBook becomes a
really great value at the base price
thanks to its portability in the end it
really comes down to whether you want to
be portable or you want that beautiful
5k display if you enjoyed this
comparison click that button above the
sub and also check out some of our other
videos right there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]